hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation part of our agilent cell
analysis global conference
my name is ned jastrum i'm a product
manager for new platforms at agilent
and will be your host for this
presentation i hope you've been enjoying
our previous speakers
to gain a better understanding about our
myriad of approaches for analyzing
cellular function
and measuring what matters most to these
cell types
throughout the earlier presentations
you've witnessed the connection between
immune cell metabolic programs
with cell state and sulfate while later
in the day you'll have the opportunity
to discover novel approaches for
measuring immune cell killing
and enabling 3d live cell imaging
applications
i'm pleased to welcome dr david ferrick
associate vice president
in agilent's cell analysis division
as our presenter for today david began
his career as a university of california
professor
then entrepreneur and currently industry
executive focused on life sciences tools
drug discovery and diagnostics
specifically in the areas of immunology
and cancer he has commercialized many
life science products
into new emerging markets based on
nascent technologies
and advanced several drug screening
programs from target identification
to pre-clinical testing he's authored
over 150 peer-reviewed publications
and has 13 patents along with several
book chapters
dr ferrick received his phd in micro
biology and immunology from georgetown
university in washington dc his talk
will showcase new concepts and
strategies
to target cancer through an
understanding of the immune response
he'll discuss purpose-built applications
that enable real-time measure
of immune cell function fate and fitness
david has been leading our efforts
resulting in a combinatorial cell
analysis tool bench
which provides the capability to measure
engineer and control immune cell
function
thus enabling translational researchers
and
drug developers to achieve the necessary
level of therapeutic
potency and safety but before i hand it
over to david a couple of housekeeping
notes there will be a question and
answer period
immediately following the talk and to
help us to get to as many of your
questions as possible
we encourage you to type in your
question during the presentation
david's passion for driving innovation
and science is contagious
and an inspiration to all of us within
the cell analysis division
and for me personally with that i'll
hand over the presentation to you david
thank you so much ned i really
appreciate that uh
coming from inside the tent that's uh
quite um a pleasant i appreciate that
so um as ned said we hope that
everybody's enjoying their day and what
i'm going to
attempt to do here is take a lot of the
topics
that have been addressed by many of the
speakers today
and try to pull them together with some
of the newest
thinking and ideas and how
our tool set is helping enable and
you as investigators to make that
progress
i know that there's not a person
listening to this presentation
including my mother that doesn't
appreciate uh
the third wave of uh therapeutic
modalities what is being roughly
referred to as cell and gene therapy
first being small molecules followed by
biologics which are predominated by
monoclonal antibodies
and now cell in gene therapy which is a
big part of immuno oncology now it's
really leading the way
in that third wave and i think it's
really important
to look at some some real numbers to
really understand
how fundamentally it's changing how we
target disease
with this newest modality right now
cell and gene therapies in development
are projected to surpass monoclonal eyes
which is now
a current leader uh in a couple of years
to give you an idea of just
how impactful this is and of course that
had there had to be a tremendous amount
of basic research preceding that in
order to enable
such a jump uh in this new modality and
in fact
as you can see now if you look at
the number of inds that are being
submitted to the fda
look at the jump uh in 2019 versus 18
and this is just year to date
so we're looking at a fundamental shift
in the way that we're approaching
uh how we target disease by going after
the immune system in addition to
targeting liabilities
of the pathogenic process itself and why
is that
what has caused this the fundamental
shift or pivot uh in the life sciences
approaches that stem from research all
the way to the clinic
and that is because of the unbelievable
curative nature that has been
demonstrated in such the early stage
of these new types of modalities uh and
and that has
really um caused a number of us at all
stages
of the the chain from research to the
clinic
uh to begin to adopt and include um
not to necessarily transition solely to
but to really enhance
our approaches and what we're capable of
doing what we at agilent
started four years ago what we
recognized is
things are becoming very self-centric
especially in cell-based therapies
and that the tools we need require us to
dive even deeper into the biology than
we had previously done
so we really believe that in addition to
all the tools we have now we need to go
beyond
endpoint into kinetic measures we need
to follow the biology longer
and if you're going to do that you need
to have label-free non-perturbing ways
of manipulating the cells
to look at more relevant uh biological
conditions when we do this we will have
more predictive lifestyle assays
to do things like develop standards for
manufacturing cells and it's just
not for therapeutic purposes it's also
for disease modeling which runs across
the entire
life sciences and because of the
information we'll be generating
by taking a deeper dive the digital
tools to contextualize this
information that's what we're focused on
and hopefully you will see that
in the various tools and various new
concepts that i'll allude to in my
presentation
so we last year uh
provided our inaugural set of what we
refer to as purpose-built solutions for
targeting the immune system
with these four instruments they
obviously are applicable
many indications but we've been working
very hard on
solutions and protocols that can
specifically address
uh questions in the immuno-oncology
space and these are the four that i will
limit my discussion uh and review for
today
the top two are are label-free real-time
cell analysis platforms
that give you that kinetic information
what is believed to be in a more
relevant setting where you can follow
the biology
and you can interrogate it in real time
below
are fairly recognizable technologies in
flow cytometry
uh in gene editing but we believe that
we've made some great innovation
and have some some additional value to
offer you
uh a particular customers in terms of
these capabilities
so let's start with the accelerance real
time cell analysis platform which is
based on an impedance
measurement technology it's a very
straightforward and quite simple
workflow
that is incredibly sensitive so in the
case in this example
um we have an electrical field that is
caused by electrodes these kind of
yellow dots
that runs across the bottom of the
plates and that allows
um whatever cells actually
bind and sit on the plate to impede that
feel and we can get
tremendous amounts of information
regarding their size their morphology
their motility the proliferation
cytotoxicity activation a number of key
biological features
so in this particular example we're
going to put tumor cells to do a
cytotoxicity i say we believe this
technology is one of the best
and most specific and sensitive ways to
do this type of assay
so we start by putting our tumor cells
on the plate let them grow for a day or
so
this entire setup exists in the
incubator so you can run multi-day
experiments which is one of the
powerful components of it and then after
we get our tumor cells going
we will add our t cells the t cells
because they float above
the uh tumor cells do not interfere with
that electrical field and therefore you
have an extremely specific
readout of the tumor cell death
and cytotoxicity so you can see here
that as the cells grow the cell index
increases due to the impedance increase
after we add some effector cells in this
knk cells if they're capable
of killing the tumor cells you will see
a decrease and that sensitivity look at
the effector target ratios
are much more physiologic other
technologies you have to use much higher
two to one ten to one types of effector
target ratios that are not physiologic
here you can go very very low
so here's a recent publication from
nabil ahmed's group
showing here the
uh publication of a
dual targeting approach uh to cancer
where they used
both a her2 uh and an il13 receptor
alpha 2
targeting vector for the car t cell this
chimeric energy receptor
and what they were looking for is to get
a sense of
the relative efficacy in terms of
potency of these various different
constructs
as you can see here running this assay
over several days
that when you first in the first day
we're only looking at tumor cells you
can see as they grow
they increase in their cell index at
about 24 hours we add
the various different uh car t cells and
controls
and if they're capable of targeting the
tumors and effectively killing them
you will see that impedance drop and you
can see that we can
rank order in a very sensitive way the
various different
uh constructs that they were testing in
this particular scenario
however what's very equally uh
informative
is the next slide which is unpublished
data that was done several months
previous to the published work where the
nabil ahmed's group was testing various
strategies
different co-receptors different varied
tweaks to the construct
to enhance immunoactivity in these car t
cells
in an optimal way and you can see here
when you look at the earlier work when
you're trying to figure out and optimize
which strategy might work most
effectively you can see
in the orange and pink two constructs at
a very low ratio of one to ten
were very effective in the early days
but you see here around day three or
four
that the tumor starts to grow back and
these are very
key events that we often miss in other
types of assays
and we know one of the great challenges
of immunotherapy is
not just getting the immune cells to
effectively
address the pathogenic process but
actually to persist because we now know
that the tumor the microenvironment and
many factors can limit the effectiveness
of the immune response and so here's a
very great way of being able to identify
these
and what's really interesting uh to keep
on building on this story
is just last year a new version of the
excelligence system this impedance
system came out that now has three
channels of fluorescence
and this now adds a whole new dimension
of additional measurement modality that
can provide
so much cellular uh context to
the in this case the cytotoxicity data
to keep this story going
well how can this benefit what what more
value can this bring
to these sets of experiments well if you
remember
we noticed that these two constructs
here in the earlier
optimization work gave a very similar
type of effect on the tumor cell in
terms of cytotoxicity
and then they both kind of departed here
and what you can see
by imaging the tumor cells is the
spatial resolution
in addition to the temporal context of
this kinetic assay
and what they learned i i can't show a
movie here but the movie is
is jaw-dropping is that actually as
the uh cars target the tumors they form
this foci
and there are actually tumors that are
resisting for an inter
intermediate period of time you can
actually see them growing and
essentially resisting the cytoplastic
effect at different levels
and then when they start the tumor
starts to overcome you can see how
spatially that occurs and it's different
between these two very
similar constructs in terms of
cytotoxicity but you can really tease it
apart
with that spatial context so this is the
extra additional qualitative information
that can really help understand what's
going on mechanistically
to design a more optimal approach
so let's move on now to seahorse xf
analyzer
this is another label-free kinetic assay
that can be run on cells
this one is measuring essentially
metabolic energetics
in living cells and this is
fundamentally changed how we think about
applying metabolism to biology it's been
a wonderful experience to see how
this field has grown and quite frankly
at a very high level
measuring metabolism is the actual
working end that's the physical way that
a cell goes about proliferating
or dividing and so it's a very direct
measure we believe it's
it's the new way to measure biology or
one of the new ways to do that
so what what is what is it actually
measuring for those in the audience that
may be unfamiliar
it measures the two quintessential
pathways in energy production
on the left in blue is mitochondrial
respiration and on the right
in red is anaerobic glycolysis these two
pathways together
are measured in real time meaning you
get a rate you know
how active they are on a per minute
basis
and and so this essentially is
responsible for generating
all the energy that a cell produces to
meet its demands
as well as well as flowing carbons for
biosynthetic purposes
and equally important that we're
beginning to appreciate much better is
redox homeostasis
which is critical and redox can be the
simple difference between
a physiologic and a non-physiologic
state
what we've learned in the last five
years specifically is the ratio of the
contributions of these two
dominant pathways actually form a very
unique ratio that seems to be
qualitatively
relevant to support certain phenotypes
that i will talk about
and is therefore added tremendous uh
usefulness in terms of not only
understanding
how an uh a particular cell can meet its
demands and how it functions
but by altering the metabolic programs
we now have understood that we can
change the biological
outcomes and that has dramatically
opened this field up
into the arena of translational and
interventional medicine
the field of imminent metabolism
effectively started around or the modern
era i should say the modern era
effectively started around 2009 with a
couple of seminal papers one of which
i'm showing here
by erica pierce where she showed this
very simple
but very insightful discrimination
in terms of metabolic programming the
bioenergetic ratio of aerobic
to glycolytic processes that relates to
very specific
cell types and their function effector
cells which are highly proliferative
that are also differentiating into fully
effective cells by producing antibodies
or cytokines
or direct killing uh infected cells have
a very high anabolic
uh need and so they not only use aerobic
but very significantly
increase glycolytic function as you can
see here on the left hand side
in contrast memory cells which start off
with a lower demand
and have to be extremely stable and very
long-lived that can last for 20-30 years
take a more aerobic strategy to support
their needs
and it actually enables them to be much
more easily triggered
and provide a much more robust second
response to the pathogen
so this very simple dichotomy set up
on the notion that different
bioenergetic
programs or poise will support different
types of functional attributes that may
be important
not only for understanding but
intervening in disease
and how how did this proof of concept
get going well very shortly after
erica's paper madhu sukumar and rick
mustifo's lab
asked the question well if i only alter
metabolic energetic pathway making a
cell more aerobic or more glycolytic
could that on its own affect the outcome
of an immune response
and he did this in a very classic
transfer model where we transfer
educated t
cells from one animal to another so we
presume we're only transferring that
single factor
and we see how protective those animals
are to
the antigen they've been trained to in
this case it's a melanoma
tumor and so by increasing aerobic
activity he did this by using 2d
oxyglucose
so this is a way to inhibit glycolysis
so on the left-hand side e-cars are
measured glycolysis
you can see after a three day treatment
with low doses of 2d oxy glucose the cd8
cells
from these animals are dramatically
reduced in glycolysis if you take the
ratio
of the aerobic rate over the glycolytic
rate you can see
that as their glycosis decreases their
overall aerobic
nature has increased if we now transfer
these and challenge these mice
you can see that by simply making the
cells more aerobic
the animals were more protected he also
did the reverse experiment where he made
the cells more glycolytic
and got increased degree of killing uh
in these cda t cells so this was the
first concept
that altering metabolic programs could
actually alter those outcomes
if we shift forward a few years to the
carl june work
we can see that various different immune
modulators such as the co-receptors
which we now appreciate how
fundamentally they're important
for both turning on and off immune cells
at the appropriate
time and showing that actually these
co-receptors
actually will in this particular paper
will actually induce
various different metabolic poise so the
401 bb
tcr zeta which is the canonical if you
will
car 19 um uh t cell
that was the one that is now uh being
used to treat patients uh
for blood tumors worked very well uh in
blood tumors but didn't work well as
they started to shift to solid tumors
however in certain solid tumors cd28 co
receptor t-cells work better
and it turns out that one of the major
differences between these two constructs
that only differ by the
co-receptor is 41 bb stimulates a much
more aerobic
uh program that leads to characteristics
of persistence and central memory
as i showed in the erica example and um
and also the madu
example whereas cd28 drives a more
glycolytic programming
that is more consistent with effector
function
and so it's not that you need one or the
other it really
probably depends on how the patient is
presenting we now appreciate that almost
all cancer patients
are making some type of immune response
that somehow gets paralyzed
and if we knew exactly where that
compromising condition was
we could go in with the right supportive
approach in this case you could see how
this could be one of the strategies that
you might add
to a car t cell strategy
and greg delgad followed up he did a lot
of work showing
that aerobic metabolism which makes a
lot of sense to a biogenesis
is is a very um robust
system to work in a hostile tumor
environment aerobic metabolism
allows cells to derive
energy and biosynthetic precursors from
multiple nutrients
so it's really good in a
nutrient-deprived environment
as well as providing resistance to
stress and oxidative stress on things
like this
and so greg asked the question in this
study if i
simply increased aerobic metabolism
using therapeutic antibodies and
clinical trials
could that somehow improve the patient's
responsiveness and persistence and
and and help further protect them or
we'll say um
support the immune response so here is
anti-cd28 and 41 bb
here you're looking at just a 24-hour in
vitro stimulation of cd8 cells you can
clearly see 41 bb
which is consistent with all the the day
i showed you
provides a much more aerobic phenotype
in these cd8t cells
if you then do the next level of
experiment which again is a proof of
concept of how a dosing regime
might improve this metabolic poise of
aerobic metabolism
here you're looking at three day in vivo
treated and sorted cd8 lymph node t cell
so three days treat with these various
antibodies
and see what the metabolic poise was of
the cdat cells from these animals
and you can see that 401 bb was superior
in raising
the aerobic metab metabolism
in these cells and then he did the next
experiment which was a proof of
a kind of therapeutic regime so
once a week for five weeks injected
animals with either a control
isotype or anti-pd-1 which is obviously
known to be helpful and has data shown
that
it does increase aerobic metabolism at
some level
antipedia one plus 401 bb um
401 bb has been shown to be toxic in
certain studies
uh so they did the last regime which was
once a day for three days before
mbb followed up by pd1 as you can see
here
that last treatment was extremely
effective
in reducing term of burden again showing
that proof of concept
the last thing i want to show you here
is um some most recent
unpublished data from the carl june lab
um
very appreciative of roddy o'connor who
did the work uh
in that program um a professor in the
program in that group
and and what you can see here is there
has been some recent
um uh papers that have shown that
higher doses of arginine in uh
and cell culture can increase
mitochondrial
respiration and so they ask the question
since when we
engineer t cells we then expand them
before returning to the patient in an
autologous approach could we actually
engineer
some desirable attributes such as
persistence by increasing mitochondrial
respiration during that expansion
process
one of the things that the car t cells
have been very unsuccessful
up to to now is in targeting solid
tumors
so this is a solid tumor model a
prostate uh tumor model
targeting a prostate um antigen and you
can see here
that if you culture these cells in four
millimolar l-arginine
high doses versus the normal you can see
a much
uh significant increase in this vivo
model in term i'm sorry decrease in
tumor burden
uh in this particular in vivo
solid tumor model and uh if you look
at what's going on by looking at the
respiration using the sea horse and
other car
you can see that you can treat for seven
days
and then what they did here at day 15
they washed out the arginine at day
seven
so you're looking at an additional eight
days without arginine
but you can see it maintained this
increased
aerobic uh metabolic poise
which you know based on the previous
work might be a way to
improve persistence uh when returned uh
to the to the individual
so in summary what we've learned
is that the bioenergetic state the
contribution of both aerobic
mitochondrial and glycolytic pathways
have a very qualitative nature in
supporting
the appropriate state or cell fate as
well as the functionality
and that we can actually follow the
transition between these equilibriums
by monitoring the rate at which for
example glycolysis can increase
during proliferation and activation and
we see that these cells have very
different states
when the immune system is working
correctly
that's why most of us are very healthy
we're repelling
infectious and pathogenic processes
continually
however one could argue that we only
experience chronic viral
or chronic disease such as cancer when
something has compromised the immune
system
in some way and what we've learned very
recently
is one of the ways to do that is simply
to prematurely reduce mitochondrial
activity
and this leads to an actual exhaustive
phenotype and these exacta cells
although not dead are non-functioning
and there's some early reports where you
can actually turn them back on
in some of the car t studies where
they've retrieved
uh in relaxing patients some of these
car t cells
we now can appreciate from recent
studies that one possible way to
um essentially make the cells
condition them to be more resistant in
those hostile environments is by
increasing by various means
mitochondrial activity whether it be
through constructs or some type of media
conditioning
before i move on to the nova site and
the share guide that i'll spend a couple
minutes with
i just want to share with you um that we
have a new product
out that's being released just released
and that is
the a new seahorse um
next generation platform to replace the
xfp mini
our smaller system that runs more
precious dedicated samples
and we're calling it the hs for high
sensitivity mini
and what's different about this new
instrument from
the instrument that yeah the xfp
well first of all we've dramatically
improved
its ability to resolve small differences
in respiring cells
and that's extremely important for
people doing immunology work or work
with cells that are in a resting state
because their energetic status tends to
be lower
also we've really designed this for
workflows using suspension cells which
again
to help out individuals especially in
immunology
and so what we believe it really expands
the kinds of things you can do
and increases the types of experiments
that were
somewhat out of reach before uh this new
tool
here's real quick what the data looks
like what really where this cell matters
is in these
lower respiration ranges where it's
harder
to see significant differences between
cell types
you can look here at the standard
deviation rates on the same exact cells
being run on the xfp
versus the xf mini you can see how
dramatically
improved the data quality is because we
can now discriminate
with higher confidence at lower rates
another
great um uh attribute of this new system
is
we went to the cloud we fully enabled
our analytics that now are accessible in
the cloud
this is the first fully enabled a
cloud-enabled platform and all platforms
that we
generate going forward will be fully
cloud enabled and i
i don't have to explain what that means
to the younger people in our audience
that gives you full accessibility
collaborative potential
moving information around accessing what
you need when you need and where you
want to do it
so we believe this is really going to
you know set our customers free
and enable people to be much more
flexible uh and to be much more
directive in the work that they're doing
um this is an example of some of the
kits that are coming out this is our new
t-cell activation kit
designed for human cells we provide
everything
necessary the assay kit with all the
reagents we have pdl coded places what's
going to dramatically improve
the quality of adhering suspension cells
in a very
relevant state for doing this kind of
work and opening up this early window of
detection
you can see here how amazingly um
robust the data is and you can barely
see
the uh standard deviation bars here
especially on the cd4 versus cd8 t
cells you're looking at activation as a
measure of proton efflux rate
which is our measure of glycolysis
the last thing i'll leave you with
before my last two topics
uh is an actual preview this product has
not launched yet but we're so confident
of the timeline
and where we stand that we are quite
confident by the end of this year
we'll have it available to you and by
simply altering
the uh consumable the hs mini plate
we can impr increase dramatically the
signal
that you're getting from our biosensors
and what this does is allow you
to use fewer cells something that we
know many of our customers ask us about
especially when you're
dealing with sorted cells or let's say
infiltrating lymphocytes
cells that are hard to get a hold of
that you're never going to fill up a 96
well plate with
now we have a solution here's what a low
cell number count would look like in a
normal plate done on an xfp
here's what it looks like done in this
new ring well plate and i think you can
agree with me that
that's a very significant improvement in
the ability to discriminate differences
uh with fewer cells so we're very
excited about this
uh and can't wait to get this out to uh
you all
so let's change gears for the last two
that i want to talk about and that is
now
flow cytometry it's incredibly
useful and very popular tool especially
among immunologists uh and so what's
different about the novacite
quantian line that we have uh through
our acquisition of asea
it's bringing the latest and best
of uh performance
number of colors and really
robust uh activity to the benchtop
so these cytometers bring a capability
that you normally have to go to a core
or you need someone that's pretty well
trained if not highly trained
to do this work to the bench top where
really it now becomes a common tool a
democratized tool that pretty much
anyone in the lab can use
it's won several awards for the fact
that it's so easy to set up
it's almost essentially automatic shut
down things that make it really easy to
move from one user to the next
but it brings all the power of new
silicon
based photo detectors that really
provide
extreme sensitivity and the ability to
really discriminate colors without
making
manual adjustments or other things that
require quite a bit of knowledge to do
so we're very excited about this
particular tool
it blends very well with the other
real-time analysis tools in terms of
characterization
here's just a very simple example
looking at a cd19
panel for a car t cell you can see here
that you have a number of different
subsets and different
markers differentiation activation
markers that can be
interrogated but what's really cool is
it can run both beads and
cells so you can look at bulk cytokines
you can look at intracellular staining
so it really expands the type of
of um by piano and analysis you can do
as we all now appreciate
cytokine storm has become a real big
deal something that's probably always
been there
we just never appreciated until
immunotherapy and now with covid and
infectious disease
this is becoming a key thing we need to
understand better in immunology and
being able to look at both cytokines
and immune subsets at the same time is
going to really be extremely helpful in
doing this
and we believe that this particular
platform is ideally
uh designed uh to do this we also going
to be looking at combining it with our
other cell analysis platforms
so you can get the best of both worlds
in this case you have an incelligence to
give you this
nice kinetic readout of the biology in
combination with being able to in this
case sample the media
at various time points run on the nova
side to assess
all the different soluble factors such
as cytokines
granzyme and other mediators of
cytotoxicity
and with that this brings us to our last
uh tool and solution that we want to
share with you
uh again gene editing needs no
introduction
uh and i know that many of you are
probably using this tool and
and using and gene editing in the
laboratory is definitely very tractable
very useful and it's it's obviously
improving every day but as you move
downstream
uh into drug discovery and into clinical
uses such as engineering cells
some of the early work has has just
begun
to happen the efficiency and the
accuracy
is not anywhere near where we need to be
so many people are working on ways to
improve
the overall fidelity uh and
um accuracy of this approach and
many of you may not know i had no idea
before i joined agilent
that uh through the um through a number
of acquisitions
they have now have in through the
manufacturing development
we are actually a world leader not just
in producing dna
uh and rna oligos and synthesis but
actually the quality and we produce the
longest and highest fidelity both dna
and rna oligos
why is that and how how we're able to do
that we
use a chemical synthesis process to do
that and it's highly robust
so a few you may know that agilent came
from
hewlett-packard many many years ago and
they know how to print really well
and we take advantage of that kind of
printing technology with
chemical synthesis to allow us to
generate
would argue we can get up to 160 tumors
with dramatically
high purity which really improves
stability
and activity and targeting of various
different
guide rnas but that isn't really the big
deal the big deal
is the ability to modify these uh
chemical
entities that we're using um as the
various base pairs
and by chemically modifying we can
dramatically improve not just stability
but actually specificity so we can
really begin now to
work away at improving both the
efficiency
and accuracy of doing gene editing
here's an example
of what that looks like a couple of
publications on the left
looking at improvements in stability ms
and msp
are these chemical modifications uh and
on the right
looking at reducing off target uh
edits uh shown in yellow again
by various uh um modifications uh to the
actual base pairs themselves
we provide all the way from research to
gmp
large scale production so for those
people doing translational work
you don't have to switch um the source
uh and you can ride the entire way with
the type of uh guide you need at the
right configuration for wherever your
work demands it to be
and so with that i appreciate your
attention today
uh i hope that um this has helped maybe
tie together
uh some of the work that you've seen
from some of the various presenters
today
was no accident that many of them use
these tools uh
in their laboratories and again just to
really focus
down and let you know that we're we
believe we need
tools to play with all the things in
your toolbox
but ones that can really allow you to
dive deeper into the biology to get a
richer and a more relevant so you don't
have to do as many experiments
so you can really be more confident that
what you're
looking at your conclusions is likely to
translate further downstream
uh and so this is what we've been
focused on
everything i shared with you today is
actually in a single electronic book
that we developed
last year that has all the links and
ways to just have a very simple short
read
that goes over a lot of the material if
you just search in google for agile
breakthroughs in
immunotherapy it gets you right there
you can download that book and it can
send you in any number of directions
depending on
uh what you'd like to know it also has a
lot of references and authors and
your colleagues on there and how they
are in many cases they are driving the
field forward
on utilizing these tools and ways to
help them do that type of work
so with that i appreciate your attention
and i'm happy
to answer any questions that anyone
might have
thank you david i will now start the q a
portion
of the webinar if you do have a question
you'd like to ask
please do submit it uh we'll be able to
get to most of the questions before the
end of the hour
um however even if we don't uh make it
to your question we'll be forwarding it
to david and the agilent team and we'll
be following up with you
so um let's get started
so the first question david that we got
was
um why is it that t cells are increasing
their
glycolysis due to the fact that that's a
less
efficient energetic pathway to obtain
that energy rather than
relying on the mitochondrial respiration
post activation
yeah it's a great question even though
we have some what i would
call kind of um didactic or some simple
responses that are somewhat
generalizable
there's still a lot we don't know but
the the very simple straightforward is
that um
a glycolytic glycolysis
is something that happens in the cytosol
that's not nearly as
organized as an organelle where the
mitochondria resides
and because of this glycolysis has the
ability to turn on
immediately and respond to immediate
demands biosynthetic energetic and redox
in a way that that mitochondria is not
similarly capable
of doing and so you know a very simple
analogy would be that when everybody
runs
no matter how in shape you are you don't
start out aerobically
you start out glycolytically that's
where the lactic acid comes from
especially if you're sprinting
but we know in order to sustain a high
level of demand we need that
mitochondrial system
to kick in now that was an
oversimplification there are many more
uh nuances associated with there are
things that both systems do
that are somewhat overlapping and can
clearly compensate
but there are many things that they seem
to be uniquely able to do so for example
we now know that certain cytokines are
connected to glycolytic enzymes in terms
of their
regulation at the protein level so there
has been an evolutionary
rationale for connecting some
of the intermediates of metabolism
that's a succinate and fumarate
for things like inflammation uh in ways
and so
i think the best way that we tend to
understand and think about it is
again our pathways our transcription
factors the various pathways the
um the sarcs the mix the p53s
they actually don't do any work they
tell others to do work the actual
work in the cell is these metabolites
and these pathways that either form
energy
or biosynthetic molecules so it makes
sense that no matter where you are
upstream and no matter what type so look
at 401 bb
is a great example how does 401 bb play
out
its effect it's one of the outcomes of
it
is a clear increase in mitochondrial
respiration that's how it physically
mediates the effects of methylation
demethylation and other pathways
so hopefully that provides some color
for this but again
please um we have some simple um
um correlations and maybe a little more
than simple
but there's still quite a bit that we
don't understand
and now that we have better tools i
think every day we're seeing
more and more insight now deep chandel's
lecture that he gave i think a couple
lectures before this
it's a perfect example of what we know
and what we don't know
and how we can start to get to those
answers so i'd really recommend
that of viewing that one amongst uh ping
chi ho hong voci
and some of the others that really are
driving into this uh
this understanding
thanks david the next question that came
in was
again about t cell persistence and
within our technology profile can you
portfolio rather can you predict
t cell persistence knowing the
bioenergetic profile of t cells
um and uh the the
person that asked the question also
asked you know we'd like to hear your
comments
on what you think in terms of modifying
some metabolic genes to promote
mitochondrial activity
in an adoptive cell therapy setting
great question there's a lot of work
going on as you might imagine not all
that's being made public
there are a lot of companies that are we
know that
cell therapy is the newest modality it's
a living drug it's so different from the
other modalities
that we're just now learning how
what are the quality attributes that are
needed and how to design those
attributes
into that particular product i showed
you an example where you can hardwire it
in the case of 4mbb or cd28 it's more of
a hard wire
and then i showed you a case with uh
increased arginine
how you could uncondition it for example
um so the first thing persistence
associated with mitochondrial activity
is pretty straightforward decades of
understanding of mitochondria it's the
quintessential element of viability
it's probably the most direct measure of
cell health that one can make and we're
just now beginning to learn
how to derive those nuances so so that's
pretty logical and straightforward
but your question about how best to
um adapt to a situation where the
pathology is
in in a consequence of some interruption
of what would otherwise be a normal um
phenotype
for the cells so on one hand hardwiring
it let's say through a
car construct maybe that could have some
adverse effects right
um you know leading to some of the
adverse effects we see because if the
cells
don't become quiescent after they're
taking over the
pathological process could you have some
immunopathology associated with that so
that's one of
one of the concerns in fact some
companies are thinking of suicide
switches that they're kind of
engineering
others are looking orthogonal types of
cytokines they can engineer so that only
the cytokine they supply to the patient
will only specifically
uh affect the immune cells kind of a way
to try to separate from the cytokine
adverse effect that is being seen in a
lot of situations
so i think the field right now is
extremely open
in terms of how women do it i think the
um
we know there's a lot of correlative so
a couple companies
have actually looked at the ratio i i
have to be careful what i say here but
but um there have been some studies
where they as you know um
they freeze down um the the car t
um products they have and then after
nine
twelve months they know um from the
patient data who were complete
responders partial non-responders
and they've actually gone back and
retrospectively they thought those and
they run metabolic analysis
and there are some data that is
correlating with this
increased aerobic um uh poise
uh leading to more complete responses so
they're
they're in the early stages i'd say it's
a little bit beyond proof of concept but
it i wouldn't say it's been an
established um standard by which people
can begin
to um uh qualify right on these various
processes
yeah that's an interesting comment that
you made about
the balancing act of controlling those
two major energy producing pathways i
tend to think of it as a as a seesaw
and effect one and the other one gets
affected
and figuring out similar to the
combinatorial approaches with
many drug discovery programs that that
comes into play at the cellular level
with these
cellular-based therapies as well that's
right uh ned and in fact um
i i assume our audience can maybe still
see the slides
uh and if that is the case i just pulled
it up but in that slide that i showed
you
where we kind of graphed out um the cell
types
there's actually some evidence now that
the cells
um oscillate so let's see if it comes up
in this now i didn't put in here but
but to your point in a normal immune
response you may be oscillating between
exhaustion and persistence
that is being titrated by the presence
of the pathological process
and so it's a dynamic interplay it's not
like the immune system with all the many
cells knows exactly
what level of um um you know exhaustive
turning off and turning down you know
it's constantly probably tweaking
the immune response in in in reaction to
how
the pathogen is uh trying to evade
um immune surveillance right so it's a
dynamic process so your point
net about this cycling is important see
the thing we need to remember about
metabolism which is different
than how we study a lot of our pathways
and a lot of other
types of um you know omics and and say
flow
is metabolism is always in an
equilibrium so it's always moving
between equilibriums we're trying to
stay within an equilibrium
so if you think about how metabolism is
helping
the immune system oscillate to find that
optimal poise
to not to overcome pathogen but not too
much so it causes immune pathology
but just enough to bring the pathogen
down until it's overcome
and then quiet the whole system down to
wait for the next
reappearance so you begin to look at it
in that way it starts to become
tractable
and it even more reinforces the idea
that we need kinetic tools
because how do you begin to model this
kind of cycling of back and forth
between the host and the pathogen
if you don't have those kind of tools
right uh so that's
that's part of the reason that we've
been so focused on this approach
yeah and missing missing those important
windows with lifestyle analysis
becomes more critical in that
experimental need
um okay i think we've got time for one
more question even though we have more
and again we will follow up
um to answer these after the fact
um yeah here's one
so how many can you give us an example
of how many t cells are needed to run
an xf assay um and and what you know
some of the advantages are compared with
measuring mitochondrial mass on a flow
cytometry for example
right well it's um for flow cytometry
did they ask or for
uh what advantages what advantages
compared to
measuring mitochondrial mass as an
example as a comparative example by flow
cytometry
ah ah very good very good so clearly
flow is very advantageous in that you
get a single cell
as well as a population very quickly
that's a great thing so you get some
idea
of the spatial resolution right uh
whereas the xf technology right now is
measuring that bulk population right
you currently can't do those kinds of
assessments at a single cell level
so to your question um um again greg
delgoth who i mentioned
uh and and please look them up um they
have started to validate
some uh reagents that would be amenable
to flow that would give you an idea of
relative
mitochondrial mass now it won't give you
a rate it won't give you that
quantitative but if you now combine
which he does if you look at his papers
the one i showed the presentation
he does xf uh raid analysis
to really understand the phenotype and
the quantifiable phenotype that exists
and then he uses flow to do more of a
qualitative analysis
and very beautiful work where he can
show very nicely that immune cells
entering the tumor microenvironment have
an appropriate level of mitochondrial
mass he uses this um
this miter tracker fm reagent to do it
it's in his paper
uh and then once it enters the micro
environment it's the environment that
really
shuts down the respiration you can see
very nicely by flow
um it's it's not quantitative but it
follows a very nice qualitative change
and then he uses the xf to do that now
we're working hard and as you saw with
the xf so numbers of cells so you know
the numbers of cells you need for flow
an hour very few a few thousand
you can do pretty much what you want
unless you're looking at rare cells
on a normal xf experiment if it's a cell
line you're in the
you know 30 50 000 range if you're in
primaries especially immune cells
you're probably somewhere between two
hundred fifty thousand to five hundred
thousand
i think most people are getting more
down to two fifty or so
in that ring well i showed you on the hs
mini that could get you down to that
fifty to a hundred thousand
um sell per well range which would
dramatically open up experiments like
tills and things
that are really average or you got to be
going through a lot of mice
uh to get there so hopefully that gives
you some
um sense or range of what we're talking
about in terms of sales and that again
comes back
to the reason we have an hs mini versus
the 96 so we know there's some
experiments that will never fill up a 96
well
because you have this kinetic data and
can do injections you can generate a lot
of rich information from a single
experiment
so a lot of people don't need as many
groups they don't need to mun uh
a full 96-volt plate even if they have
sufficient cell numbers
to get the kind of quality data they
need and that's how we found that
both have a place uh in the lab in fact
many of the labs that do a lot of this
um have access to both
because there are times when one uh is
the right format and there are times
when the other is
all right well thank you again
david for sharing this state-of-the-art
interconnected
tool bench in our cell analysis vision
engineered to support the exploding
needs of this really fast growing market
and special thanks to all of the
audience
for supplying the questions and your
participation today
um and so with that we thank both the
audience and david
and enjoy the rest of our talks today
great thank you all